Çeviri: Nora Ahmed
Gözden geçirme: Sevkan Uzel
Dünyadaki en büyük mucize,
iki insanın birbirini
anlamasıyla başlıyor.
Benim tüm otuz küsur
senelik hayatımda edindiğim
bazı cümleleri
paylaşacağım bugün sizinle.
Bu cümlelerden bir tanesi bu.
Bu cebimizde kalsın.
Ben 3 yaşında
İstanbul'a göç eden;
ben 3 yaşındayken,
ailesi İstanbul'a göç eden
bir ailenin üç çocuğundan
bir tanesiyim; en küçüğüyüm.
Adıyaman'ın Besni ilçesinde doğmuşum.
Annem babam da oralı
ve işi dolayısıyla babamın,
İstanbul'a gelmişiz.
O yaşlarıma döndüğümde
gördüğüm Ayşe, şöyle bir Ayşe'ydi:
3 yaşında İstanbul'da
o dönemki Türkiye'nin
standartlarının altında
bir ekonomide yaşayan
çok mutlu bir çocuktu.
Yıllarca kendime şunu sordum:
Neden bu kadar mutluydum,
ne vardı bu kadar mutlu olacak?
Neydi biliyor musunuz?
Benim annem çok mutlu bir kadındı.
Hâlâ çok mutlu
ve ben onun gözlerinin
içine bakardım.
Annem mutluyken
benim mutlu olmamam
gibi bir duygu olamazdı.
Böyle hissederdim
ve çok mutluydum.
Annem mutluluk da
cebimizde kalsın şimdilik.
3 yaşında İstanbul'da
yaşayan bir çocuk.
Her gece ama her gece,
istisnasız
başımı yastığa koyduğumda,
kendi kendime şunu soruyordum:
Yıllarca, hâlâ
"niye geldiğimi" sorguladım.
Buldun mu diye sorarsanız,
birtakım cümleler buldum.
Ama bu sorunun cevabını
%100 bulmuş değilim;
süreç devam ediyor.
Ama şunu keşfettim:
Daha küçücük yaştaki bir çocukken,
bu soruyu sorarken,
geceleri kendime sorarken,
gündüzleri de tüm hayatımı
hâlâ tüm hayatımı
acaba bu sorunun cevabını
bulabileceğim bir şeyler
öğrenebilir miyim, diye geçirdim
ve bu sorunun cevabı
hâlâ o kadar yakınlarımdaymış
gibi hissediyorum ki,
sanki bir taşı kaldıracağım ve
altından bu sorunun cevabı çıkacak.
Ayşe, dünyaya şunun için geldin!
Bütün insanlar aslında siz dünyaya
şunun için geldiniz.
Bunu birinin karşıma çıkıp
söylemesini çok istedim yıllarca.
Ama geldiğim noktada,
bunu kimsenin söylemeyeceğine
eminim artık.
Kendimiz bulacağız
ve inanacağız.
Ama hep bu arayışta oldum ve
çok mutlu bir çocukluktan sonra
90'lı yılların Türkiyesi'nde ergen oldum.
Zor bir ergenlikti,
pek çok ergenlik gibi.
Sonra üniversiteye gittim.
Üniversitede,
-- fen-matematik öğrencisiydim --
Türkçe-sosyal kazandım.
Olmaz dediler insanlar.
Saçmalama sen fen-matematik
öğrencisisin, ne alakası var?
Nasıl Türkçe-sosyal bir branş
yazıyorsun, dediler.
"Ne demek olmaz?" dedim.
Çünkü o daha küçücük Ayşe'nin
kendi kendine sokakta oynarken
söylediği sözler vardı;
bozduğu ezberler vardı.
Dünya, ezber bozarak daha güzel
bir yer hâline geliyordu.
Bir oyun öyle oynanır; hayır
öyle oynanmak zorunda değil.
Bir de böyle oynayabilir miyiz?
Oynuyorduk ve çok eğleniyorduk.
Öbürünü zaten çok oynamıştık.
Bunların hepsi bende şöyle
bir alışkanlık yarattı:
Dünya, kesinlikle ezberleri
bozduğunuzda daha güzel bir yer;
sizin için de, başkaları için de.
Ve ben çocukluğumdan itibaren
şuna inanmaya başladım:
Dünyada, evrende, bu düzende
gerçekten imkânsız diye bir şey yok.
İmkânsız diye bir şey yoktur.
Buna inanmayan insanlar vardır.
Düş kurmayan insanlar vardır.
Ve bu düşleri için yeterince
çalışmayan insanlar vardır.
Ben bunu bizzat yaşadım.
Başkalarının yaşanmışlıklarından
gözlemledim.
Hâlâ yaşıyorum, daha da
bir sürü şey yaşayacağım.
Kesinlikle imkânsız diye bir şey yok.
Ben fen-matematik öğrencisiydim;
Türkçe-sosyal kazandım.
Gayet de güzel kazandım,
üniversiteye girdim.
İletişim fakültesi birinci sınıfa girdim.
Okulda kitaplar...
Hızlı öğrenmeyi seviyorum.
Ah dedim ben iletişim fakültesinden
mezun olursam ne olacağımı,
galiba şu an burada öğrenemeyeceğim.
Çünkü o kadar yer fazlası açık ki,
gazeteci olabilirim, sinemacı olabilirim,
reklam ajansında çalışabilir;
reklamcı olabilirim.
Piyarcı olabilirim.
Bir sürü şey var; hangisini olacağım?
Ben ne olabilirim? Çünkü hep
o sorgu var bir yandan.
Ben niye dünyaya geldim?
Ne yapmalıyım?
Ait olduğum şey ne?
Bir soru daha soracağım.
Sizce bu dünyadan hiçbirimizin
sağ kurtulma şansı var mı?
Yok. Ben bunu hiçbir zaman karamsar
bir düşünce olarak düşünmedim.
Dedim ki bunun çıkışı var;
hepimiz için var.
Herkes için var.
Lütfen bunu unutma Ayşe,
bu işin çıkışı var.
Exit'i var; çıkacağız buradan.
Buradan sağ kurtulma ihtimalımız yok.
O zaman bütün hayatı buna
göre dizayn edebiliriz.
Aslında yaşam dediğimiz şey bir plansa,
doğumla başlayan ölümle
biten bir plansa bu -ki böyle;
ben bunu nasıl planlamalıyım?
Ben niye buradayım? Neden varım?
Bu soruları sorduğum dönemde
iletişim fakültesindeydim.
Daha sormaya devam ettiğim dönemde.
Ve kendi kendime dedim biraz
daha öğrenmeliyim, ne olacağım ben.
Çünkü şöyle bir şey fark etmiştim;
o çocuk Ayşe büyüdükçe
dünyanın birtakım düzenler kurduğunu,
bizim aslında insanların dünyaya
birtakım düzenler kurduğumuzu
ve kurduğumuz düzenlere
kendimizi hapsettiğimizi fark ettim.
Bu düzenin tamamını bozabilir miydim,
tek başıma durarak?
Bozan insanlar vardı;
ben onlardan biri olabilir miydim?
Çok istersem olabilirdim;
çünkü imkânsız diye bir şey yok.
İstiyor muydum bütün dünyayı değiştirmek?
Herkes birazcık ister belki;
biraz daha mütevazı davrandım orada belki.
Dedim ki ben nereye ait olduğumu
biraz daha anlamak istiyorum.
Ve birinci sınıftan itibaren
çalışmaya başladım.
Türkiye'nin en büyük
gazetesinde çalıştım.
Türkiye'nin en büyük televizyon
kanallarından bir tanesinde çalıştım.
En alt düzeyden
ne iş olursa olur diye girip
belli bir yerlere geldim;
ama yaptığım şey gözlemlemekti.
Çünkü bir yandan
üniversitede okuyordum hâlâ.
3. sınıf 4. sınıf reklam ajansı,
halkla ilişkiler şirketi;
hepsini gözlemledim ve
mezun olduğumda,
"haydi Ayşe artık
bir şey ol" diyordu herkes bana.
Ben ne olmak istediğimi hâlâ
çok net bilmiyordum.
Bu kötü bir şeydi, çünkü insanlar artık
"maymun iştahlı bu kızdan da
bir şey çıkmayacak"
diye tepki göstermeye başlamışlardı.
Ama ben gerçekten ait
olduğum yeri hâlâ arıyordum.
Ve bir gün düşünürken
kendi düşümü kurmaya karar verdim.
Ben bir şirkette çalışabilirdim;
çalışmayacağım dedim,
kendi düşümü kuracağım.
Peki, nasıl bir düş olabilir?
Güzel bir şeyler yapmak istedim.
İnsana dokunan bir şeyler
yapmak istiyordum.
İletişimi çok seviyorum,
insanları çok seviyorum,
dokunmayı seviyorum,
konuşmayı seviyorum.
Kitle iletişim araçları heyecan veriyor.
Psikolojiyi seviyorum,
sosyolojiyi seviyorum.
Bunların hepsinin birleştiği
ne olabilir diye bir fırsat arıyorum.
Çünkü inzivaya çekilip tek başına
yaşayacak bir insan değilim.
Bütün dünya düzenine karşı koyabilecek
kadar güçlü hissetmiyorum kendimi.
Ama insanlara bir şey söylemek istiyorum.
30 senedir, o dönem 25 senedir
bir şeyler öğrenmişim.
Bazı taşların altından
bazı cümleler çıkmış.
Çok sıradan cümleler aslında,
unutmuşuz sadece.
Birine söylediğimde, kahve içtiğimizde
güzel bir etki alıyor.
Bunu daha büyük kitlelere duyurmanın
bir yolu olmalı, ne olabilir?
Ne yapabilirim?
Film mi çeksem? Sinema hiç fena değil.
Buralarda gezinirken....
Ülkesini, bu toprakları, doğduğu yeri
çok seven bir Ayşe Şule olarak,
kendi kendime dedim ki, Türkiye'de
niye çizgi film yapılmıyor?
Niye kimse yapmamış?
Çok garibime gitti, bir an hızlıca
şöyle bir geçmişi düşündüm.
Kendi çocukluğumdaki çizgi filmleri...
Ve şu an çocukların izlediği
-- 8 sene öncesinden bahsediyorum --
çizgi filmler,
her şey yabancı kültür baskısı altında.
Christmas'lar, Cadılar Bayramı,
büyükanneler
büyükbabalar havada uçuşuyor.
Ve bizim kültürümüzden hiçbir şey yok.
Hiçbir tane karakter yok.
Eyvah dedim, biz çocuklarımıza
kendi kültürümüzü anlatamıyoruz ya!
Niye anlatamıyoruz?
Ecnebi bir sürü şey yapıyor;
biz neden yapmıyoruz?
Çünkü dedi birisi, bu finansallara
dökülmeyen bir iş.
Bundan iş çıkmıyor Ayşe,
ondan kimse buraya girmiyor dedi.
Nasıl dedim, araştırdım
çok hızlı bir şekilde.
Çünkü çizgi film yapmak,
çizgi filmle bir şey söylemek
inanılmaz heyecanlandırmıştı beni.
Sanki o çocukluğumdan beri sorduğum
sorunun cevabına yaklaşıyormuş gibiydim
ve kendi kendime dedimki,
Ayşe nasıl olur ya?
Niye yapmamış insanlar,
bir araştırsana.
Hızlıca araştırdım ki aslında çizgi
filmin Türkiye'de yapılmaması için
gereken ne varsa mevcut.
Ne o? Yetişmiş iş gücü: Yok.
Nasıl yapılır?
Birkaç çizgi film sevdalısı
bir araya geldik.
Bir çizgi film yapacağız.
Nasıl yapılır bilen yok.
Bu nasıl seri üretime dökülür?
Bilen yok.
Haydi hasbelkader kadar
yaptık çizgi filmi.
Atladım o dönem çalıştığım
o çok büyük kanala gittim.
Çünkü çizgi film de yayınlıyorlar
sabah kuşağında.
Dedim ki ben yerli çizgi film yapacağım.
Kimse inanmıyor.
Bir ezber bozacağım. Türkiye'de yerli,
bu ülkenin topraklarından beslenen,
bu ülkenin çocukları gibi konuşan
bir çizgi film yapacağım.
Orada söylemek istediğim küçük
cümleler, kelimeler var.
Bunları söyleyeceğim insanlara.
Siz dedim, yabancı yayınlayacağınıza aynı
yeri ve aynı parayı bana verir misiniz?
Veririz Ayşe, dediler.
Dünyanın en mutlu insanı oldum.
Peki dedim kaç para veriyorsunuz?
Bunun sürdürülebilmesi için
o paraya ihtiyacım var.
Dedi ki Ayşe, vallahi 100- 150 dolar
veriyoruz dedi bölümüne.
Ben o dönem çok hızlı
bir fizibilite çalışması yapmıştım.
Birinci bölümü 150 bin dolara
mal edebiliyorum.
Eyvah dedim, neden yapılmadığı çok ortada.
Çocukluğumdan beri
imkânsızlığa inanmıyorum.
Bu dünyada imkânsız diye bir şey yok.
Her şey yapılır Ayşe.
150 dolara vereceksin.
150 bin dolara üreteceksin;
Bu nasıl imkânlı olabilir!
Nasıl imkânlı olabilir?
Uzunca bir süre buna bir imkân bulamadım.
Ve herkes dedi ki yapma,
bak ne kadar imkânsız ortada.
Dedim bunu yapmak istiyorum,
inanıyorum.
Ben bu ülkenin ortalama bir vatandaşıyım.
Bu ülkeyi çok seven,
gerçekten o Türk filmlerindeki
klişeyi yüreğinde yaşayan,
yurt dışında biraz fazla kaldığında,
Türkiye'ye döndüğümde gerçekten
toprağı öpmek isteyen biriyim.
Ben atalarımın, dedelerimin değerlerini
çocuklara aktarmak isteyen biriyim.
Bunun yapılabileceğini inanıyorum.
Bu toplumun buna ihtiyacı
da olduğuna inanıyorum.
Burada kolektif bir bilinç
yaratılabileceğini düşünüyorum.
Çünkü ben gerçekten ortalama
bir Türk vatandaşıyım.
Bu ülkenin ortalama bir vatandaşıyım.
Bu benim ihtiyacımsa,
bunu bu ülkeyi seven bir vatandaş olarak,
ben o kadar net hissediyorsam,
bu koca bir toplumun ihtiyacı
olabilir dedim ben kendi kendime.
Böyle büyük büyük konuştuğumda herkes:
"Ayşe sen de nereden abartıyorsun,
yani ne alakası var?
Kaç tane insan gördün vah vah
Türkiye'de niye çizgi film yok diye yakınan?"
Ya görmedim ama hissediyorum dedim.
Ben bunu yapmak istiyorum.
Ve çizgi film yapmaya başladım.
Tüm imkânsızlıklara rağmen
ecnebinin 150 kişi yaptığı
işi 3 kişi yaparak
dördüncü bölümü
yapmaya başladığımızda,
bir televizyon kanalı kuruldu.
Devlet çocuk kanalı.
%70 yerli yayın yapacağım dedi.
Tamamen doğru zamanda
doğru yerde olmaktı.
Herkes proje dosyası götürürken
biz bölüm götürdük.
Bölümü götürdük, izlediler.
İlk kabul edilen proje oldu.
Yayına çıktı.
Hiç kimse tanımıyordu.
Hayallerimiz vardı içinde.
İlk günden itibaren
bu ülkenin çocukları için;
önce bu ülkenin sonra bütün
dünyanın çocukları için
harika bir içerik olacak bu dedim.
İlk günden para kazanma
ihtimalımız bile yokken,
uzman psikologlar, pedagoglar,
çocuk gelişim uzmanları,
benim bütün okumalarım,
ekibimin katkılarıyla
bir çocuk 104 bölüm Pepee seyrettiğinde
hangi kazanımları elde edecek diye
haritalar çıkardık biz.
Sanki bütün dünya, bütün evren
bizi bekliyordu.
Ve biz ona hazırlanıyorduk.
Öyle hazırlamıştık
ve Pepee yayına çıktı.
Çok kısa bir süre içerisinde...
Bizim ne pazarlama bütçemiz vardı,
ne bunu duyuracak
başka kanallarımız vardı.
Sadece çok iyi bir çizgi film
ürettik, yayına çıktık
ve birden bütün Türkiye birbirine
Pepee diye bir çizgi film var
duydunuz mu, dedi.
Siz Pepee'yi duydunuz mu?
Ve çizgi film yapmak istediğimde
bütün yetişkinler bana
şunu söylemişti:
Bu bir deli işi, bundan
iş çıkmaz Ayşe, yapma!
Ben bir parka gittim,
bir çocukla karşılaştım.
Okuyor musun, dedim.
Evet, dedi.
Sen ne iş yapıyorsun, dedi bana.
Ben çizgi film yapacağım, dedim.
SÜPER bir iş, dedi.
Hepimizin itiraf etmesi gereken bir şey.
Yetişkinlik bu dünyada
bize verilmiş en büyük ceza.
Çocukluğun hapishanesidir yetişkinlik;
günümüzde.
O yüzden içimizdeki çocuk çok önemlidir.
Çok değerlidir. Çocuk deyip
geçmeyin yolda gördüğünüzde.
Onlar bizden değil.
Yetişkinler ve çocuklar;
ikisi aynı şey değil.
Ayrıyız, çok başka bakış açılarımız var.
Çocuk olmak bu dünyanın
en güzel şeyi.
Halk oyunlarını koyacağım dedim Pepee'ye.
Yine yetişkinlere sordum
ilk olarak.
Artık yetişkinlere önce
sormuyorum bu arada.
Dedim ki, ben dedim,
süper bir şey buldum.
Halk oyunları! Deliririm;
türkülere bayılırım.
Ve bunu Pepee ile
çocuklara duyuracağım dedim.
"Ay Ayşe, son teknolojiyle
çizgi film yapıyorsun;
halk oyunu mu koyacaksın içine," dediler.
Ya dedim, halk oyunu,
benim atalarım, dedelerim
nenelerim yazmış onu.
Ve Youtube'da daha çok izlensin,
şu kadar daha fazla para kazanayım, diye
yazmamışlar o türküleri.
Gerçekten bir şey yaşamışlar;
yaşanmışlıklarını koymuşlar.
Bir acı hissetmişler, aşk yaşamışlar.
Üzüntü, kayıplar...
Her şey gerçek yaşanmışlık.
Sen buna burun kıvırıyorsun şu anda.
Çünkü sen yetişkinsin, dedim.
Sonra bir çocuğa sordum tekrar.
Dedim ki ben Pepee'ye halk oyunları
koyacağım, ne diyorsun?
"Ne? Oyun mu?" dedi.
Çocuk için oyun çok değerlidir
ve ben Pepee'ye halk oyunlarını
koydum; türküleri söylettim.
Şu anda milyonlarca çocuk Türkiye'de
horon tepiyor, çayda çıra biliyor,
halay çekiyor.
Bazılarının anneleri ona gülüyor;
bazıların anneleri "Ay benim oğlan da
halay çekmeye başladı," diyor.
Çocuklar bayılıyor o türkülere.
Çocuklar efsane gibi seviyorlar
halk oyunu oynadıkları için.
Müfredattan kaldırılan halk oyunlarının
Pepee'den sonra tekrar müfredata
girdiğini biliyor musunuz?
Neden?
Çünkü kolektif bir bilincimiz
var aslında bizim.
Ve Pepee sadece bunun gün ışığına
çıkmasını sağlıyor.
İhtiyacımız var,
samimi şeylere ihtiyacımız var.
Biz gibi olan şeylere
ihtiyacımız var
ve biz Pepee'de ilk günden beri
anneyle çocuğu birbirinden ayırmadık.
Konuşmanın başında size söyledim;
dünyanın en mutlu çocuğuydum ben;
tüm imkânsızlıklara rağmen.
O gün evimize belki
500 gram kıyma girmezdi;
bundan hiç mutsuzluk duymazdık.
İnanılmaz mutluyduk. Neden?
Annem çok mutluydu;
anneler çok önemlidir.
O zaman dedik ki: Biz anne-çocuk
iletişimi yapacağız.
Biz çizgi filmimizle yaptığımız işle
kitlelere ulaşabiliyoruz.
Ve o zaman o kitlelere
anne-çocuk tandansında
bir şey söyleyeceğiz dedik.
Ve bir gün böyle bir resim geldi.
8 sene sonra.
Bu resim bana çok acayip şeyler anlatıyor.
Pepee dergisi çocuğun sırtındaki.
Burası sanırım Güneydoğu
Anadolu'da Mardin olabilir;
bir il.
Ve kolektif bir bilincin,
yaratılan bir bilincin
bir anneyi köyden çıkartıp
çocuğuna Pepee dergisi
aldırabileceğini gördüm.
Kimse taşrada dergi satmaz derken,
demek ki aslında ihtiyacımız olan şey
sadece bazı şeylerin üstünün
örtülmüşlüğünün açılması.
Biz bunu yapmaya çalıştık
ve ilk günden beri dedik ki,
bunu bir işe de çevireceğiz.
Pepee bir işe de döndü.
Hiç kimse de dedi ki,
çizgi filmden para kazanılmaz.
Ben bunu amaç olarak koymadım.
"Ben bir çizgi film yapacağım ve öf!
Öyle bir para kazanacağım ki!"
Asla demedim,
ama dedim ki öyle iyi
bir iş yapacağız ki
bunu izleyen, devamının gelmesi için
bize para kazandıracak
ve Pepee bir işe de döndü.
O işin sonunda para da
kazanmaya başladı.
Kazandığı parayla yeni çizgi filmler
üretmeye başladı
ve bugün sadece Türkiye değil,
Youtube'a yazın Pepee Rusça yazın.
Şu an Pepee Rusça konuşuyor.
Rusya'ya girdik.
Çok yakında Arabistan.
Kolektif bir iş dediğimiz aslında
dünyanın her yeri.
Ve aslında ne dedi Pepee?
''Farkılıklar hayata renk katar''
dedi mesela.
Biliyor musunuz bu şarkıyı?
Evet!
En çok hangi şarkısını
biliyorsunuz Pepee'nin?
İki ekmek?
Benimle söyler misiniz?
Birazdan bitireceğim.
Hep beraber bir söyleyelim mi?
İki ekmek aldım
1, 2, 3...
♪ İki ekmek aldım ♪
♪ Eve gidiyorum ♪
♪ Biri büyük, biri küçük ♪
♪ İki ekmek aldım ♪
Süpersiniz!
Neden sevdik bu şarkıyı?
Çünkü hepimizin iki ekmek almakla
ilgili çok tatlı anıları var.
Çok samimi bir şey var
ve bu bizim kolektif bilincimiz.
Burada hiç gidip iki ekmek
almayan var mı aranızda?
Yok, hepimiz bir gidip
iki ekmek almışızdır.
Pepee, ''farklılıklar hayata
renk katar'' dedi.
''İnsan sevdiğini hiç üzer mi?" dedi.
Üzer mi? Üzmez.
''Bana beni sevdiğini söyle,'' dedi.
Sevmek çok güzeldir.
İnsanların birbirini sevdiğini
söylemesi çok güzeldir.
Üzüldü ve "kalbim kırıldı'' dedi.
Çok samimi şeylerdi bunlar.
Ah be Pepee "bakma bana öyle;
seviyorsan söyle" dedi.
Ve Ayşe Şule de diyor ki:
Ezberleri bozun;
imkânsıza inanmayın.
Bu dünyada imkânsız diye bir şey yoktur.
Bu dünyadan hiçbirimizin sağ çıkma
ihtimali de yoktur.
Yaptığınız iş her neyse,
bu düsturları unutmayın.
İçinizden, kalbinizden, yüreğinizden,
eğer bir şeyi tutkuyla yapmanızı
söyleyen bir ses varsa,
o hapishanedeki küçük
kızın söylediği şeydir;
küçük oğlanın söylediği şeydir size:
Yetişkinliğin içine hapsolmuş
çocuğun söylediği şeydir.
Lütfen çocukların
söylediği şeyleri önemseyin;
kulak verin, değer verin.
Hiçbirimizin sağ çıkma ihtimali yok ya;
bu hayatı güzel geçirin;
ezberleri bozun.
Ve hayatı içinizden geldiği gibi,
çocukça, o çocuk duygularınızla yaşayın.
Teşekkür ederim.